uh yo shout out to you and your wife
congratulations thank you so much much
much love and uh and and prosperity to
your marriage amen and the wedding is
coming December December 2nd one of the
most stressful days of my life oh I've
been married before I mean I am married
right now I said like I'm not me you're
[__] up in this game
my wife don't watch this no it's a very
stressful you gotta get the Caterers you
got to get the food you got to pick the
flowers uh how much is your wedding
gonna cost
a couple hundred thousand uh half a
million Jesus
yeah almost almost half a million what
are we doing here I don't know just buy
a house yeah
you can buy like a yeah baby you have
almost half a million
she said
how much
Thirty hundred thirty three I mean a
thousand oh
you're over budget if we're over budget
then yeah it's almost like so when I get
over budget on my wedding I just started
to uninvite people that's what we're
doing
I was like
when they told me okay look this is how
much it's gonna cost because you have
200 people coming I was like I will what
is it if I have a hundred what if I cut
that in half
and they told me I was like all right
we're just gonna invite 100 people we're
trying to cut a lot of things but for
not like almost like 300 000 almost four
it's like it's like I said it's like
almost a half a million wow
you could buy a lot of uh a lot of lots
of things with that yeah it is a it's a
for me it was one of the most important
days of my life and my wife's life so
yeah whatever it takes to make her happy
and make her like the Dream well the
most important day of your life was the
ceremony you had at your house because
now you guys are married exactly so this
is a really cool like also kind of cool
day to like you know give your wife her
dream wedding exactly yeah this is for
her this is for her yeah this is my
greatest gift for her well you're so
romantic yes sir Jay wheeler the new
album's coming soon hopefully October
trappy trappy yeah appreciate you
pulling up brother thank you thank you
serving me here